all right sir I was like doing that and
it works against the barns officer right
good evening everybody my name's Andy
Crump
thank you against the vod's like to
welcome everybody to tonight's meeting
of Stratford dish councils planning
committee
the meeting will follow the procedure on
the inside cover the agenda and again I
like to take the opportunity to ask
everyone to insure their mobile phones
are either turned off or set on silent
there's nothing worse than hearing the
theme to the Great Escape in the middle
of her speech of representation or they
also like to remind everyone that any
registered speakers are allowed to speak
and could members of the audience
refrain from interrupting or heckling
speakers however tempting that may be a
lot to introduce the top table starting
on my right base of those legal services
I'm Richard Gardner on the planning
manager in my role is an impartial
advisor to the committee I can clarify
any planning issues that arise doing so
I'm bound by the code of Professional
Conduct to the Royal Town Planning
Institute planning committee members not
bound by the case officers
recommendation or by oral advice Eddy
wrench senior planning officer Louise
Casey thank you any new politics
Robson's thank you can see Richards
disclosure of interests no thank you
so yes thank you for that catch the
brain is it just want to declare that I
attended a site visit of 17 Oxford
Street yesterday along with councilor of
in catch the Barnes I went today and I
also had an email from somebody about an
application okay thank you yeah I'm
warden member for that one and I will be
stepping out in asking cancer party to
join a meeting minutes okay that I sign
the minutes of the meetings held on the
30th of May and the fifth of June as in
the papers thank you will now move on to
the first item on the agenda which is
application number 4 which is 18 / 0 1 0
to F Llewellyn 17 Oxford Street side
them and I will pass that on to testify
good evening everybody and welcome to
the first application that I shall be
chairing has councillor Crump advised I
am an Perry vice chair of planning East
the application is number 18 forward
slash zero one zero seven two /f ul the
site is seventeen Oxford Street seldom
and the description the development it's
the develop demolition of one dwelling
and various industrial buildings and
construction of five dwellings and
associated works now like to hand over
to the case officer Eddie wrench for a
presentation thank you
Thank You chair the applications site is
located within the center of salvan
within the built-up area boundary and
conservation area and is denoted here by
the black dot the site is accessed off
Oxford Street to the east existing site
is formed of one dwelling and industrial
buildings to the rear which are all in
disuse the river snow runs just to the
west of this site and can be seen here
can we just hold for counseling st. but
I can confirm that as I've just entered
at the start you men
sorry if we can just wait for council
site just to settle okay when you're
ready thank you
this is an aerial view of the
surrounding area showing the existing
built form the application site is
bounded by red in the center this is the
proposed site plan of the five dwellings
showing three connected dwellings to the
front and two semi detached properties
to the rear 13 car parking spaces to the
center of the site the amenity space to
the rear of each dwelling included in
the works of the widening of the
existing access to the front of the site
as shown here on to Oxford Street also
to the bottom of the slide is the
proposed levels on the site this slide
is showing the proposed three dwellings
to the front of the site in relation to
the street seen at the top of the page
at the bottom it shows the rear and side
elevations of the property as well
property sorry this is the floor plans
for the same properties so the two to
the right plots two and three are over
three storeys plot one is over two
stories this is the plans and elevations
for the two semi-detached properties to
the rear of the site with the floor
plans shown on the bottom right-hand
side and the front and rear elevations
and also the levels on the site to the
top left-hand corner this is a view down
Oxford Street of the application site
which includes the front wall and
stink property and the existing access
this photos in the opposite direction so
in the application site on the right
hand side this is a gain down Oxford
Street looking along the foot way which
runs across the front of the application
site this is the side boundary of the
site and also the access to number 16 a
Oxford Street this is a view from it
within the site looking back towards the
existing dwelling and showing some of
the buildings to be demolished on the
left and right hand side this is a game
within the applicants application site
looking towards number 19 in the
background this is within the site
looking down towards the river stove
which is beyond the buildings shown this
one shows the existing site back towards
the existing access which is through
between the existing building which is
to be mulish and the neighboring
property
this is looking at the South southern
boundary buildings and walls with the
dwellings along Oxford Street to the
rear this is a photo from the rear
garden of number 19 Oxford Street
towards the application site in the
background and finally this is a view
from the garden of number 16 with the
existing boundary wall and buildings
sewn just behind the existing vegetation
Thank You chair the updates as you said
before there was a member's site visit
held yesterday with councilor council
Perry and councillor fielding in
attendance
there's also details of what was seen
and the breed that was taken on that
site visit there is a 13 additional
letters objection highlighted in the
updates is also an updated
representation from the Environment
Agency and WCC highways confirming that
they have no objection there's also an
additional comments from salvan town
council there's a few minor amendments
and additional conditions also listed
chairman the recommendation is to grant
for the reasons detailed in the report
thank you thank you for your
presentation I'd now like to invite
councillor Mike Brooks from South and
Town Council to come forward
please take a seat at the front you have
three minutes if you'd like to turn your
microphone off off at the front would
you find it helpful to have a 10-second
warning towards the end or you quite
fine so in in your own time we just
start when you start to speak thank you
before I make my statement can I just
advise the committee that the additional
comments from South and Town Council
that shown on the update report don't
relate to this application they actually
relate to another application which is
six more oh thank you for that
notification so we are to ignore the
comments on the update sheet thank you
yes
over to you okay thank you the Town
Council has from the outset objected to
this application proposal in its present
form we have two major concerns the
first the intended demolition of the
existing early 19th century property
itself the council takes protection of
its conservation area very seriously as
to our residents testified by the 130
comets lodged objecting on these same
grounds I made a site visit in May with
another counselor and we concluded that
the shell of the existing building
looked to be structurally sound and had
the potential to be restored to its
original condition consequently the
council called for an independent
condition report to ascertain if
restoration is achievable the conclusion
reached by a Bromwich Hardy for the
applicant states that the property is
tired past its best and not in keeping
with the street scene but makes little
or no comment on its structural
integrity an external only a site visit
has also been made by a member of the
Georgia group who refutes all the
comments made in this report stating
also that whilst it is not a listed
building it makes an important
contribution to the overall conservation
scene comprising as it does a variety
mixed stars materials and finishes core
strategy policy cs8 section b or
paragraph b states that proposals that
could lead to substantial harm or total
loss of significance of designated
heritage assets will only permitted
where the substantial public benefits
outweigh the harm or loss Southam is in
the process of delivering 1100 news
Wellings across six sites the result
when the build phase completes will be a
growth rate of 40% over a very short
period of time add to this an appeal
will be heard in this October on a
further two hundred twelve eggs on Ross
Road West and the uncertainty whether
potential reserve sites will be included
in the essay P then we can safely say
that Southam is more than pulling its
weight in developed in delivering new
housing for the district hoping to
maintain that healthy five-year housing
land supply the question we asked then
is it in the public interest to demolish
a heritage asset in the conservation
area that could be restored
just to construct another fire
properties in our opinion the answer is
no new housing and sell from yes but not
at the expense of losing our historic
assets no matter how small a part our
second objection concerns the proposal
to narrow Oxford Street at the site to
provide wider visibility space the
councillors of the opinion narrowing the
road by moving out curving will add
another dimension of a drivers and
cyclists to bear in mind when
concentration will be focused forward
this is one of the major routes out of
town and vehicle traffic is expected to
increase substantially as new housing
gets taken up thank you obviously
practice that well spot on councillor
Brooks can I invite members of the
committee to ask if they have any
questions
councillor Barnes yeah we could have a
picture of this street senior I was just
concerned about this in your last point
there was going to narrow it but the
building next door is wider than that
one coming down yes that's true as I
understand the drawings the curbing will
be moved inwards yes that obviously will
have an effect on slowing down traffic
but difficult road to navigate this
series of twists which leads up to
market Hill and as I can tell by the
picture at the moment there is legal on
street parking opposite the factory shop
so drivers actually do take an extreme
amount of care when navigating this road
any further questions from councillor
Richards thank you you've heard to one
of the buildings is a heritage asset I'm
assuming still wanted to be demolished
has that got a listed status or any
other official heritage title I seem to
have missed a pimp at up and picking up
in the report no it's not a listed
building
architectural II it's it's not a
particularly it's not actively citing
building but the issue is that it it's
it's over 200 years old and it does
contribute to the conservation scene
overall as you can tell by the picture
there was a broad variety of styles and
finishes and buildings so our point is
that it it does that significantly to
the overall street scene any further
questions I know the officers wanted
just to come back Richard Gardner Thank
You chair I'm just to pick up mr. Brooks
his point about the comments that were
made the comments received and printed
in the update sheet were received under
the reference number for this
application which is why they're in
there I can only assume that that the
reference on that was put on in error
we've got a new deputy clerk has started
about three days ago so it may well be
her fault okay so in that case it's
probably safe to ignore those comments
in the update sheet
only to those in the printed agenda yes
for the town council thank you thank you
very much councillor Brooks now like to
invite we have two representatives who
wish to make representations as
objectors angelakeen and Robert Palmer
can I invite you both up to desk
together yes a double act and you have a
combination of three minutes in total so
I don't know whether you've decided how
you're going to split you're speaking or
is it
no three myths in total would you would
you find it helpful to have a a warning
say sort of ten seconds off just before
a minute and a half would that be useful
and if you if you haven't done this
before don't worry you just turn on the
microphone with the button and you'll
get a red light stand sit sit sit
exactly where you are at the moment and
the microphone will pick it up all right
and the clock won't start until you
start to speak so slides moved on just
give the officers are nodding we can
move them forward the previous
application for six houses rejected in
January for number of planning reasons
and I along with many Southland
residents failed to see how the new
application of five houses are not six
but an increase of a thirds of forecast
basis fails to address the original
objections I'd like the council to
consider that the fact that was over 200
people took the time once again to
object to this development it must show
how usually important this proposal
build and demolition is to South them
and how much is not wanted by the
community the proposed houses are odds
with other properties in Oxford
Street and in terms of size design and
style the half-door medicine porches are
not style seen in the conservation area
this is contrary to the core strategy
policy CS point-eight the main reasons
being represent serious over development
of de site demolition of a historic
Georgian building in a conservation area
parking area of a proposed development
onto an awkward and already compromised
access number for serious flood risks
and five overlooking adjacent adjacent
properties which will reflect light and
privacy good evening
I lived in the street for 58 years it's
a nice old Street a bit a bit dirty
according to some people there you go
I object to the development I appreciate
this something has to be done with this
already but I just think that we're
perhaps trying to cram a little bit too
much in for what there is there I do
believe that the house is cave will have
been renovated there is a brick building
at the back known as the coach house
which could certainly be do your honor
baited and developed into a property it
won't make the big books the five you
know new houses would but it was done
sympathetically I do believe there is a
market for those properties my main
concern is the properties at the back of
the development will encroach and Rob
all the daylight from my garden I've
spent the last 40 years trying to
develop and turn into a shadowy area and
I do believe that you know just purely
the elevation because it's going to be
two meters plus above my ground to the
floor level I don't believe that that is
necessary if you go that high you know
the ground has been made up dramatically
as they'll find when they start
dinging and 10 seconds not it okay well
that's the thing it's too hard thank you
if you'd both like to remain seated and
I'll ask members of the committee if
they have any questions they wish to
pose no questions thank you very much
for your time for coming along this
evening we that's what I meant at the
start of your presentation if you wanted
us to show them we needed to roll them
um well we we do have you your colleague
actually stopped ten seconds before the
allotted time so if you don't remain
seated and we just run through the
pictures that you showed that we can
just see the garden I think that's more
than fair
I think that's fine but that's very
helpful thank you very much indeed now
I'd like to move on to the applicants
agent mr. Steve Bromley good evening mr.
Bromley thank you know the form but you
have six minutes yes thank you chairman
your committee visited the site
yesterday therefore you will be aware we
are dealing with a seriously derelict
sites in the heart of the conservation
air it has been unused for many years
the current proposals are an opportunity
to significantly enhance the character
and appearance of the conservation area
NASA the principal duty in this
application following the refusal of the
previous application for six dwellings
we have worked through the reasons for
refusal and we have obtained free
application planning advice from your
offices and we've followed that advice
very carefully since the previous
refusal the number of dwellings has
reduced from six to five with a complete
redesign of the buildings adopting
features that reflect local character
the height of the buildings has been
reduced the height on highway safety we
are now proposing to widen and improve
the access it's all been agreed with the
highway authority there is the added
benefit in the current layout which will
allow the neighbor to turn a vehicle
within the site as opposed to the
current situation which requires the
neighbors
to reverse onto the road on the issue of
flood risk we have demonstrated that
none of the dwellings will be in flood
zones two or three and I understand the
Environment Agency have now confirmed
that no objection to the proposals the
layout of the site complies with the
council's forty five-degree rule and
policy for the separation of buildings
there would be no looking at windows to
habitable rooms thereby protecting
neighboring properties from
overshadowing or overlooking site isn't
easy part two residential and part
commercial the house of the front of the
site is worn out and needs replacing the
commercial lands and buildings at the
rear of the site can be put a much
better use for residential purposes the
overall speed will result in significant
enhancements to the conservation area
it'll improve highway safety it could
provide small to medium sized housing in
a highly sustainable location chairman
town center derelict sites are not easy
to develop opportunities like this need
to be grasped when they come when they
come along I hope your committee is able
to support the proposals which build
will be of great benefit to sell them
just want to go over one point that was
raised by the previous speaker the
existing house isn't a heritage asset
it's not a designated heritage I said
it's not a non designated heritage asset
also there is no policy basis to require
a justification for the removal of that
building other than the general test
that does this scheme overall in its
totality preserve or enhance the
conservation area and quite clearly this
scheme does enhance a conservation area
thank
thank you do members of the committee
have any questions councillor fielding
the cyclic were you the existing house
number 17 is situated there is a narrow
entrance has it got to be widened as
shown on the plan yes this comes about
through detail discussions with a higher
authority to provide footpaths
and a five meter wide entrance which
will allow allow vehicles to pass each
other in the entrance that's how you
would end up with that width of access
it creates a very safe access any
further questions from committee
councillor barnes the the one of the
speakers or the town council said it was
going to be less safe now you were
saying it's going to be safer the bikes
because I ride a bike but I'm not I
didn't go on the bike but it will
definitely be safer the other thing we
haven't mentioned is that the footpath
will be widened so you'll have a wider
foot path that the front of these
properties the curb line will will move
out into the carriageway a little bit
that will narrow the carriageway you can
see that as a traffic calming feature so
overall a significant improvement on
Highway Safety coming back to councillor
fielding property that the lady was
showing us going down through her garden
I believe it's the wall on the left-hand
side of the development there are you
demolishing that wall are you going to
leave it in a city or to how the
southern boundary there the one that we
we haven't got as far as that in our
considerations of the design and we
would expect that that would be
requirement of a planning condition at
which point we could discuss what the
planning officers an appropriate means
in closure I suspect it will be part
wall and part fencing any further
questions I've just got one particular
question if I may mr. Bromley the
previous speaker made reference to
restoration of the existing house could
you advise us what research or
consultancy has been done about looking
at the possibilities of restoring the
existing house normal thing probably
because we don't intend to retain the
house and I would emphasize that while
senior replacement dwelling policy
there's a requirement to justify the
loss of a dwelling either demolition of
it these proposals aren't considered
under the replacement dwelling policy of
the core strategy they're considered
under the policy of redevelopment of a
brownfield site there is no requirement
to justify the loss of the existing
building not in policy terms the the
test is does this enhance or preserve or
enhance a conservation area thank you
that sources no further questions thank
you for your explanations now we'd like
to move on to any technical questions
from or sorry
wall member apologies Andy councillor
Crump how could I forget you
hello okay so there you are
you'll see I've done that in the past
Sarah I can't come in waving in Madame
chair and for the counselors firstly I'd
like to thank and congratulate hence the
Mike Brooks for his excellent
presentation which summarized the main
issue succinctly and eloquently as well
as the great comments from local
residents who spoke really passionately
obviously mr. Bromley has said how this
application is the best thing since
sliced bread and you should pass it
however I'd beg to differ more recently
if Kent says remember I am mr. Bromley
actually agreed that the application for
24 low costs local need homes were
needed inside park against the officers
recommendation to refuse we argued
logically that this development was
needed and demonstrated that there was a
significant local need and support for
us this is not the case with this
application the Georgian society as well
as a hundred and twenty-nine yes 129
people have objected this was not a from
the Town Council I'm thinking pretty
well-known in the town in the local area
and always being stopped to talk about
local issues no one has said this
development is a good idea far from it
in fact many have been quite
uncomplimentary about the developer I'm
not the James Bond character dr. no to
all developments and save them however
as the cancer is more than adequately
meeting its five-year house and non
support obligations and has its core
strategy in place we can be choosy in
what we approve say from certainly
taking a fair share of the Roman
recently with over even 100 either being
built being built or prude which is over
seven a half percent of the number in
the core strategy significantly more
than any other major all centre the
repair of the number 17 is not beyond
the wit of man we put a man on the moon
so where there's a will there's a way
recently mr. missus Forgan superb
renovation of the Elizabethan house and
a beeline just around the corner was
featured on the wrist
some programme on BBC TV with Caroline
Quentin the sympathetic renovation this
one Bernier derelict building is an
example of what can be achieved this is
also happened because mr. and mrs.
Horgan care about and live in the
community something I'm not sure that
applies to this developer there's a song
big the other taxi by Joni Mitchell with
little lyrics you don't know what you've
got till it's gone we need to ensure
that this historic asset is preserved
for future generations of so them to
enjoy it's one of the reasons why I
stood to be SDC councillor I've spoken
to local residents about this something
the developer didn't do you know I'd
respect to the town council either as it
might be considered a brownfield site
and is close to that town centre
sustainable it might be argued that this
is a good development however I must
disagree and in my opinion it is not
high quality and sensitive to the local
historic context cs8 it doesn't enhance
or preserve the character appearance of
the conservation area
it says no redevelopment of the site is
over Burlington neighbors it is out of
keeping with surrounding properties we
mentioned the sole payment of two
thousand seven hundred pound but that
wouldn't be used to provide a community
asset had it be two hundred and seventy
thousand pounds we might have been able
to find the community asset out of this
it's cancer Williams who often sits on
this committee often says and bother
like a plaster in case of Williams
because I know you're not very well if
it's not right it's wrong I tend to
agree that this is the case and in my
opinion and many safe and residents to
the officer and developer I've got this
one wrong so really remember once it's
gone it's gone
the developer needs to go away in come
back with a more appropriate scheme if
the developer had agreed to restore the
property and for it to be funded by
building two or three new houses in the
background in the background but garden
to pave the restoration I would have
probably been minded to support the
application as it stands now I cannot
and I ask members to refuse this
application for the reasons I the time
cancer
on their own local residents have
mentioned I was just one thing to add I
would disagree it's not a significant
improvement to highway safety if you
could show me that what it says that in
the report I'll be more than happy to
accept that but I think that's opinion
not a fact thank you Thank You
councillor Crump do I have any questions
from committees councillor fielding if
they're going to retain seventeen that
road which needs to be widened to get to
the back and would how would cause the
house to be demolished anyway surely
there was we're not rich we're not
retaining the proposal is not to retain
no I'm Priscilla we have to stick to
what's in front of us if they came
forward with a different application
that could be funded by that but I'm not
supporting the current application its
current form okay counselor fielding any
other further queries
I think you've obviously answered
everybody's queries Thank You councillor
Crump thank you
now I'd like to turn to officers if
members of the committee have any
technical questions they wish
clarification on councillor bonds the
update sheet there is concern over the
highway and that the update sheet it
does appear that the highways are not
now not objective is that correct yeah
there is a lot of other words with it
but then they weren't objected in the
first instance this is just an update on
some additional parking but no there's
no objection from County highways
councillor Richards Thank You Eddie I
pulled up the reasons refusal of the
previous application I just want to
understand in your mind why you think
those have been overcome so addressing
the commercial you
first clearly we've had a viper it's
much bility and viability assessment put
forward has that been independently
verified by our own consultants or we're
just taking it as read that is just
being assessed by offices and you're
satisfied very clearly and in terms of
the other two which is beta based on the
scale design and appearance overbearing
and dominating feature and combined with
that I guess that compromises the
conservation area
I haven't the benefit of seeing the
original designs I we hear that these
are different you and I'm assuming that
your reason for granting this time is
that these are materially different
smaller and of better quality design
yeah they're significantly different
over the other one in so much as
certainly there's two dwellings to the
rear rather than three and also plot one
which is the one shown as rendered there
that's been dropped down in the street
scene as well so there's quite a
reduction in any further questions we
now move forward to debate who'd like to
open up the debate don't have any takers
to open up the debate counts counsel
fielding I just feel that the street
scene is going to be so altered by
having these porches and sort of fencing
along the front of them but it really
doesn't blend in with what is there at
the present moment and I would rather
object to it councillor Richards thank
you
I disagree with cancer fielding and that
respects prash counsel did make a point
that the building that there is rather
uninspiring my view is that even if
you're going to renovate an uninspiring
building it's just a slightly prettier
newer up to date uninspiring building
these to my mind are of good quality
design
I think the officers report has detailed
why he feels that this should be granted
in policy terms and I absolutely agree
with him I think it's a very good report
and on that basis I will be proposing
that we do grant and go combination
counselor bonds well I'm sort of in
between really he's a nice old building
but it's not listed but and it's sort of
if you like bars up concerned that is
Jay so in that respect I can't see where
the safety in the highways he's coming
in and because I couldn't park on the
road but and it does appear that after
the refusal they've gone back to the
council had a word the council have come
up with this sort of scheme so I think
we're in a difficult position to be
refuses so we looked at least second the
first proposal anybody else like to make
a comment I I will put my two pennies
worth in I think having actually been to
the site was extremely valuable Oxford
Street is is like a gateway road into
the center of the town coming from the
south part and I have to say whilst the
the photographs show that particular the
existing house if one was to actually
have a picture that had the whole street
scene one can understand why there has
been so much objection to it at the end
of the day it's very rare that we come
to a committee meeting where we have an
application that has got a hundred and
twenty six letters of objection plus the
Town Council plus the ward member I I've
got concerns about this because I do
feel there is an impact on the character
of the street scene I think the warden
those comments is that they're not
saying no to development the neighbors
aren't saying no to development but at
that particular front street scene and
the character of the front see that that
street scene is clearly not only
important to neighbors in Oxford Street
you don't get 126 people taking the time
and the trouble to object to an
application and I think you know at the
end of the day if they were to build the
houses at the bank wouldn't have a
problem with that particularly if there
was a way of keeping the front street
scene so I'm actually going to vote
against the officers recommendation
because I believe there's a real
importance of keeping the Gateway
straight in to sell them and preserve
the character and I would much rather
see an application that came forward
that addressed those those issues
however we do have on the table a
proposer and a seconder for this this
application before I go to that
counselor fielding you're indicating you
wish to speak further yes if we if it is
approved then I would like to see that
particularly that wall along the south
side preserved for the garden of the
people who live there rather than have a
sort of fence the brick wall is very
much part of the character the garden
Edda can you just give some advice on
that brick wall please
through uture conditions five on page 25
of the agenda secures hard and soft
landscaping and you'll see there a
series of things that that would secure
it's possible to add in fact I've just
spotted it now I the position and design
of all site enclosures that would cover
the means of enclosure to that boundary
and if members felt particularly
strongly about it we could put a note on
any permission saying what committee
members would like to see on that
particular boundary can I also refer
members to the update sheet where there
are some amendments to conditions
condition to replaced with the
development hereby permitted shall be
carried out only importance of the
details of development are shown on the
various drawings the beginning of
condition three shall now include
notwithstanding approved plans there's
also a replacement condition to number
nine prior to the commencement of
development an appropriate
archaeological death based assessment
and if necessary field develop valuation
shall be submitted to and approved by
the planning authority so there's that
condition and there are an additional
two conditions the development permitted
by this planning permission shall be
carried out in accordance with approved
flood risk assessment which obviously
highlights a number of concerns by the
objectors on the flood flooding
situation of the site and finished floor
level to be set at a minimum of seventy
eight point fourteen and before the
first occupation of the dwellings hereby
committed the first and second floor
side windows on plots shall be with
obscured glazing but I therefore move
back to our proposer councillor Richards
are you happy with all these the
conditions raised
can we also check for clarity yes am i
my proposal was to grant in line with
the conditions laid out and report and
the in the update sheet and I'm entirely
happy for the note to be added for the
wall retention as part of a condition
five money councillor bombs on God happy
I think the wall is an added thing that
we do need to address at this particular
point and just to clarify the type of
all I'm assuming you're wanting a red
brick wall I think I think the point is
as much as possible retaining the wall
is there but where that's not possible
okay yes yeah red brick wall can I just
come in there particularly having done a
site visit on the neighboring property
there is a huge amount of mature trees
and shrubbery on that other side of the
wall and therefore but one can
understand that that needs to protect it
because of the disavow the mature plants
and trees on the other side of the wall
okay we we have a proposal to grant we
have a second second data grant all
those in favor to chairman all those
against for chairman right have a
proposer
to refuse planning permission with with
various conditions counselor counselor
fielding but based on what I said about
the street scene and what you have said
I think that there's the reasons for
refusing and in terms of your policies
for and the reasons for refusal I'll go
along with the with because I haven't
got the parts in front of my own
with what you have said counselor st.
thank you I sometimes feel that I'm the
only member of the counts that actually
lives in a conservation area when a lot
of these debates come about and it's
very easy
I understand councillor Rich's point
about the quality of development but I
think there's so alters the character or
the conservation area that is not worthy
of granting and I think we have to
stress that in our reasons for refusal
Thank You councillor st. councilor
Kendall do you wish to add to anything
to that so so we have a proposer and we
have would you are you prepared to
second that can I just ask the Planning
Manager to clarify those reasons okay
having listened to the discussion my
understanding of what committee members
would like to do is refuse it for the
reason that the development would be
harmful to the street scene in this part
of South and conservation area and the
policies that that would conflict with
would be policies cs5 CSH which is
heritage assets c s9 @ CS 15 and 625 of
the core strategy and officers could
work up a full reason to agree with you
if that would be acceptable that's fine
thank you
so we now go to the vote can can we have
a seconder councillor st. thank you you
did indicate I thought earlier so
proposed by councillor fielding seconded
by councillor st. all those in favor of
refusing Planning Commission those
against abstentions
the planning is committee resolves to
refuse planning application 18 forward
slash 0 107 to forward slash Ville thank
you
right thank you very much of that and
move on before we move on to the next
item on the agenda just like to welcome
catch the site it's good to see you
again so as I attend Thank You fair come
in tonight so good to see you Chris not
just yet all right glad to see you don't
see this very often but a keen member
this is what I like to see so I don't
care sir just move on to the next item
which is application number 18 / 0 1 3 0
to REM land east of not corrode bishops
inch in turn and Eddie will be
presenting this Thank You chair this is
a reserved matters application for
details of appearance landscaping layout
and scale following the approval of
outline the application is for 84
dwellings including 35 percent
affordable balancing pond foot way links
making it with the existing public
right-of-way which runs through the site
open space and associated works this is
a resubmission of the previously refused
committee application which was refused
on housing mix chairman or following
negotiations the recommendation is to
delegate officers following and the
withdrawal of objections from the parish
council member thank you okay before we
move on to that and which go on to our
first speaker which is catched there
kettle who would like to explain his
reasons for its removal of comments and
then we'll ask mr. chairman the original
reasons projection have been overcome in
discussions with the
as explained it is a highly
controversial application but it meets
our call structure guidelines we have to
had negotiations develop a result of
which both parish council and myself
felt in view of the recommendation from
the officer and the results of those
negotiations will be had with the
developer last week that be appropriate
for us both with to our objections
therefore both the parish council expect
the Chairman either on this evening that
I do sit on the parish council and I
both feel it's appropriate this should
be delegated to the officer to take this
further we have no objections I very
much classic little moving swiftly on I
would like to ask the meeting whether
they'll be happy to tourniquet this
recommendation
thank you very much so I just need to
sorry and also we need to take into
account the amended conditions in the
update sheet as on thank you caster
candle councillor Richards all those in
favor
University Thank You committee gazhams
today Gaddis application to offices
moving on to our next application which
is 18 / 0 0 4 5 2 ful Edmonds Cottage
Church Lane new bold on Stella
Stratford for even close just like we be
don't go to your father please and the
waves will be presenting this
Thank You chair the application out for
members is for a number of proposed
extensions to Edna's cottage the plans
also also shown minor amendments to the
existing detached garage and the
addition of roof lights within the
southeast face and briefs a planning
permission is however not required for
these alterations as they can't be
carried out under the properties
permitted development rights so the
application site identified the Phi the
black dot is situated within the village
of newbold under Starla the application
site is outlined here in red and as you
can see the site also falls within the
setting of the grade 2 listed building
linworth to the north west of the site
is a detached dwelling constructed
predominately of stone with some brick
when it featured a first floor and the
majority of properties which line the
south side of Church Lane have got the
roadside Edmonds cottage however is
situated behind these properties and
it's almost entirely off screen from
public views so the aerial photo here
demonstrates the relationship between
the properties along Church Lane and
those within the nearby vicinity and as
you can see the property's bound to the
north south and west by neighboring
dwellings with open countryside to the
east so here we've got the existing
elevations of the property so the south
east elevation up here is considered to
be the principal elevation face into the
garden area the site with the North West
elevation below that can be seen from
the neighboring garden of the property
named trellis we've got the Southwest
elevation up in the top right-hand
corner here which is viewable from the
neighboring property Linwood and finally
the North East elevation down the bottom
corner is visible from the garden of the
neighbor of property Orchard Croft and
also it's just that first floor table
and there which is visible from the
public realm of Church Lane so moving on
to the proposed elevation so the
majority of works would be to the
southeast elevation in the form of a
part two story part single story
extension
and also the creation of the first-floor
dormer window the first four extensions
also proposed for Southwest elevation
and a single-story open fortune knocks
door to the Northeast elevation the
two-story element of the extension would
be subservient a height to the main
dwelling and the proposed material
finish would be a combination of match
in stone render and weather-boarding the
only part of the development visible
from Church Lane as I've mentioned
previously would be a small section of
the roof of the proposed log store which
would be clay tile to match the existing
roof and the remainder of the work would
not be visible here we've got the
existing floor plans next so the V
creation of an additional bedroom at
first floor and additional ground floor
covers all living accommodation so
moving on now to the images of the site
this photo here looks towards the
southeast elevation because it to be the
principal looking from the garden area
of the application sorry this second
image here pan slightly to the left and
as you can see here there is the
outbuilding of the neighboring property
Lynwood the grade 2 listed property and
also the boundary warm and this is
planning to the right of the South East
elevation so we've got the neighboring
property credits behind you can see the
rear elevation of that and also
trellises detached garage there and this
is the detached outbuilding within the
application site of Edmonds cottage and
just beyond the outbuilding is orchard
Croft there this is just a close-up
photo you can see Lynwood the property
there behind with spandrel wall and
outbuilding and this is number 20
sun-filled Lane to the south of the site
this is the photo taken from church lane
and that is the only part of the
dwelling which is visible from the
public realm the neighbor of property
traders here and access into the
applications night and this photos take
from churchmen as well just a little bit
further north
the dwell into located behind these
properties here this boat has taken from
the rear garden of tread s as the rear
elevation of Edmonds cottage and the
final photo is taken from the rear
garden of the listed property Lynwood in
terms of updates we've had additional
comments from the ward member which can
be found on the update sheet and
chairman it's recommended to grant three
grant the application for reasons that
are in the report pretty much move on to
our next speaker which is coach the site
I liken this application chairman a bit
like the one we've had in Southam short
while ago earlier this evening the scale
of the objection is not there but
nonetheless it is there and it is
substantial we have a very narrow
entrance site and what is Backlund's
development which we would normally
under policy terms thoroughly thoroughly
discussed now I haven't had the time due
to my own hospitalization the behalf
spend on the background of this
application that I would have liked to
have done but nonetheless I do have
severe discomforts about it and I know
from my 20 years of representing that
particular area on this council that
there have been several attempts to
develop that site all of which have
ended in failure and as a consequence I
don't know we've got what some people
might argue is a bit of infill here a
few extra buildings the walls of which
don't effectively encroach according to
the officer's report you know on the
other hand they sit in my view
uncomfortably with the surroundings and
the people that live around there are
clearly uncomfortable with it and
therefore that's the basic principle on
which it should be refused but I have a
more fundamental objection as well and
that is referred to in the comments that
I have now made and that is we have this
document called extending your home
every time there's an awkward
application extending your home creeps
in and it's used to give a certain
amount of weight towards granting
something yet the very same report says
that we effective
looking a parking policy and we give it
limited ways now the parking policy
statements were actually went through
the democratic process last January or
February
I know because they went through before
I was ill and when I was very much
involved in the in the development of
policy in that particular area and
therefore I think that balance is wrong
we have documents have been out for
public consultation which could
contradict extending your home yet
extending your home he's used as an
argument to grant planning permission
therefore I athle regard that
recommendations are grant are certainly
premature and I would want to do if
we're going to have a look at this and
extend the property in such a way but
we'll accommodate parking then it's not
just a question of providing two places
which is what the report says it's a
question of design a question of layout
it's a question of style and that style
just isn't there it's a bit of a crude
attempt in my view to actually come
forward with a scheme that might look as
if policy supports it
well I'm afraid if we're going to have
policy we ought to be thorough about it
and we ought to make certain it's a bit
like the bit like the judge of Wells
borne you know oh here we can't discount
the fact there might be houses at wells
borne airfield one day haha we have a
clear policy that says no and we should
stick to it and therefore in this
particular case we have a clear policy
that says back land development is not
appropriate but we need proper design we
need proper parking facilities we need a
proper strategy and therefore until
those factors are in there we shouldn't
even consider granting planning
permission at this particular site it's
as if somebody's got hold of the
property and he's trying to exploit it
the sites of the full when the proposals
are a little bit premature
you're immature I might say and
therefore not not worthy of
consideration Thank You German much
against society I might know a no
challenge me I'm not necessarily going
to challenge you I just would be
interested in your views as to what
particular parts of this proposal that
that particularly great with you the
particular parties you've got a narrow
entrance
you've got back lander development and
you've got bombs on properties port on
rooms effectively which don't sit
happily within any form of street scene
or design layout any questions thank you
briefly sorry right thank you very much
now we move on to points of
clarification for the officers catch the
parry not a question I like the sound of
my own voice as I don't I would just
find it helpful for officers just to
give great more detail into the impact
of the grade ii listed the the setting
of the grade ii listed building adjacent
just that i just would like to have
agree a better understanding as to the
levels of harm from that and what what
we should be looking at from that
perspective
so Linwood the property to the northeast
it's separated from the proposed
development pipe so from the existing
property is about 10 meters but the
two-story extension it will be separated
by around 15 meters and Linwood also
sits an elevated position to Edmunds
cottage so you can see in this photo
it's a two point five meter foundry wall
which separates them and then when we
look from the photo take from Linwood
you can see the difference in height on
the wall and if you look at whether the
roof of the house sits as well the two
so extension is going to be set down I
think it's about a naught point it's
sorry it's naught point seven meters
that we set down from the ridge height
it's also going to have a hipped element
as well to to lessen the impact of of
the extension we've also got this
vegetation screen in between the
property as well
chance the bonds the early letter of
objection is concerned about traffic in
that is suitable to bullet on for
delivery
not sort of before 9:30 it's possible
that that could be put on and it would
be enforceable the question to ask is
whether it's reasonable given that the
very small scale of development proposed
there was a photograph showing the back
wall of the house there is is that that
backs onto the grade 2 listed or is that
great back just onto another property
that wall backs on to the neighboring
property treadeth which is this one here
Lynwood is this property to the left of
traders yeah that photo was taken from
the gauntlet of traders can we go back
to the on that which way does the D
development come does it come for the
show in southeast elevation here and it
projects from this elevation this is
where the 2 part 2 story part single
story aspect movie thank you though he's
questioned about the initial objections
there were six I believe but I carried
forward or what I've drawn or they
inappropriate now the objection from
neighbors they weren't withdrawn I think
we had they still currently stand
they've not been withdrawn okay thank
you right okay so then the question what
do you refer to as permitted development
what is what was the permitted
development of the site so we've got the
plans here there's an existing detached
garage with in the application site as
part of the proposal you can see the
existing garage here the proposed go to
some minor alterations to the outside so
replacements and doors and windows and
also change to a material but that's
permitted development and also not these
windows which would be in the extended
part that the roof lights on the
existing roof so they are permitted
development as well
for me one I've got objections to
hearing your voice on any occasion
cancer Pony statement right bill will
move on to the debate gets the parry I
know that defy flattered you and gave
you a confident you had to come to my
well it's nobody else has been speaking
someone's got just to start it I think
this is this is this is a difficult one
and whilst I understand and take on
board the ward members comments about
character of the village we would the
scale and size of this development I'm
just struggling to find a material
planning reason against against the
police policies to refuse it
unfortunately with any form of planning
there is an element of harm
you can't build extend without causing
some form of harm
I do have every sympathy I'm concerned
that because of the vicinity of the
grade ii listed building but at this
moment in time I'm struggling to find
proper reasons for refusing the bombs
applications the comments were about
concern about the traffic and another
thing which I would like a condition on
cancer st. I'm not sure for 20 years in
going on about proper concern like the
last week I can't really see a reason
for refusal that word aloud and with the
parish council support I would like to
propose it with the condition of
delivery at the appropriate time which
in my eyes is after Harper's Island
any any further chance of falling yes
they need to comment I've got is the the
garage in the parking and the run-up to
the garage is that within our policy or
our policy to be approved for the number
of cars to the number of bedrooms
I see me referring to the merging SPD on
parking standards the proposal would
result in a three bedroom for which
there would be a requirement for two
cars so in this case there would be
three parking spaces provided one in the
garage and two in front of it right
we've Anna proposed owner seconder
Richard the balance is raised the
construction time is that it could be
argued it's reasonable given the
narrowness of the lane so rush hours
there may be conflict which could result
in highway safety issues so it is in my
opinion just about arguable that it's
reasonable to exclude deliveries
relation to this development from the
our stated although I would perhaps a
nine o'clock it's the more usual bonds
are you happy without the condition yeah
I'm quite happy with that my thoughts
were 9:30 you know because the school
crossed the road and whatever you
proposed how for your second death for
that proposal catch the founding
so yeah so you're second in the proposal
just to make sure yeah Leslie just okay
thank you right we've got a proposed in
a second all those in favor proposal
five chairman unanimous thank you
council resolves to grant application
1805 to ful when they move on to our
next item which is going to be presented
by Eddie which is application 1800 676
ful Nolan's cottage for the bedliner
Winton demolition of existing dwelling
and construction of two pairs of three
birds semi-detached Runnings we'll just
wait for Eddie to get settled
thank you Jeff Katz Barnes Council
filled in we excuse me gentlemen we
haven't won me - no we haven't
- today thank you you can discuss the
dog afterwards Thank You Eddie sorry
about the application a site is located
on the southeastern edge of the village
of a Linton as denoted here by the black
dot site is within the Cotswolds a OMB
and within the cotswolds fringe special
landscaped area the site consists of a
single bundle o accessed off featherbed
lane to the north east to the south and
east of the site are open fields
directly to the Northwest Vista
cul-de-sac no is closed which is shown
this is an aerial view of the site
showing the surrounding built form in
the area this is the proposed site plan
showing two pairs of semi-detached
properties one pair fronting featherbed
Lane and one pair at 90 degrees facing
onto the open countryside to the east
these are the proposed elevations of the
properties numbers 1 & 2 which are the
two fronting featherbed Lane all the
dwellings share similar architectural
features and would be constructed
constructed in a local Cotswold stone
with artificial slate on the roofs this
is the two other dwellings which are
slightly off the road which face out
onto the open countryside to the east
this is the proposed floor plans for the
four dwellings which would all be
3-bedroom this is a photo from
featherbed lane looking towards the
existing site the bungalow is shown on
the left-hand side and that face is at
90 degrees to the roadside you can see
some of the properties in the vicinities
on the right-hand side again this is a
closer view of the existing access which
would be widened to accommodate the
additional dwellings also the existing
bungalow on site this is a view back
down at the road with the application
site on the left you can see that
there's quite a variety of dwellings
mainly from early 20th century this is
from within the site looking back out
towards the access notice all the
agricultural fields surrounding the area
this is a close-up view of the bungalow
on the site and also in the background
you can see the property's melons closed
this is where the two proposed dwellings
fronting the road would be situated
against the gable of the neighboring
property this is another view from
within the site the access would be
taken just to the right in front of the
red brick dwelling across the road this
is a view from the very rear of the site
looking out onto the open countryside
beyond another shop just of the of the
existing site with the side elevation of
the bungalow shown and that concludes
the presentation updates include one
updated report from the applicant on
some of the issues raised and chairman
EA recommendation is to grant permission
for the details and conditions
highlighted in the report thank you
thank you I think that's very clear
we'll move on to our next speaker which
is a furnace from ailment and parish
council what was it mr. Osborn and can I
ask who are you mr. Osborn
you put that microphone on please I'm
Gerald Osborne yes and did you register
because we've got Sara furnace it's it's
Sara furnace the Clarke
Sara furnaces the clock yes okay thank
you very well have advised you that I'm
coming to represent the council I think
she might not quite have done that in
that in the prescribed by but I'll see
this is a problem not a problem for good
good I've often been told to be turn it
off so all of them okay
okay chairman the parish council objects
to this application we do not object to
the site's use for residential
development and supported its inclusion
within the evolving neighborhood
development plan for three dwellings
subject to the plans policies this NDP
has concluded its section 14
consultation and we are advised that
some weight should be given to its
policies our main reasons for this
objection are sewage disposal and
parking in a report commissioned by the
District Council issued in 2012
Ellington's wastewater treatment works
was considered to be quotes at its limit
of consent with current housing levels
solutions are required to accommodate
growth in 2011 following sewage
discharges onto arms foot Road 7
translated that the long-term solution
was to increase the capacity of the pipe
linking to this treatment works since
2011 21 dwellings have received planning
permission in Hillingdon there is no
evidence that additional capacity has
been provided by 7th rent in March this
year's sewage was again forced from a
manhole onto a public highway
the NDP includes a policy intended to
prevent new developments from exacerbate
in these problems it requires them to
firstly store discharges of far water
and prevent its discharged until
capacity is available and to prevent
foul water from bat feeding from the
sewer into the property much of
Ellington was built before the motorcar
causing our problems today are on street
parking and the resultant congestion in
a rural community with little public
transport
each adult family member will likely
have their own vehicle a three-bed house
will often have three vehicles parked
outside it the NDP requires new
developments to provide one parking
space
the District Council's guidance is
appropriate for an environment well
served by public transport that we
cordially submit that this is not the
case in Ellington the application
provides eight spaces we consider this
inadequate the plan shoul D space is
disposed so the vehicles park one behind
another the consequence is that the
second vehicle will have to move onto
the highway to allow the first to exit
the overall result will be vehicles
moving and maneuvering onto the road and
much on street parking next to a road
junction unbend on one of the main 15
seconds can I just say one set centers
the parish council requests this
committee to reviews permission for this
application until the proles the
proposals have been amended to resolve
these matters in line with the policies
of the availab of oving and deplete a
spot on motor questions for i'm just
very briefly you mentioned 21
permissions have been granted how many
of those permissions have been built you
know practically all of them okay that's
great thank you sorry when you look at
some of this history i was the war
member thrilling turn it got changed
about a bit and councilor brain took it
on sort of three years ago but
effectively I remember this plot it is
an untidy plot and there are plenty of
spaces within it in order to drive
vehicles so I'm just wondering why we
are told that parking is inadequate are
you asking that's an indirect question
are you asking that the EPS last long if
what is opinion of the parking is in the
area is that what you're trying to say
because the application proposes to
parking spaces
dwelling the dwellings are three
bedrooms our view is that as I tried to
point out in the presentation that in a
rural community such as helming ttan
most adult members of the household have
their own vehicle so the three-bedroom
house will only have three vehicles
parked outside
that's correctly I thank you very much
yeah so I think between the two you've
you answer that question very well thank
you cancel fielding you put your mic on
please the road gang along the south
it's that a private road or is that it
is a proposed private road and it is too
narrow for cars to maneuver along it so
effectively the cars entering the
parking spaces can only enter and leave
they cannot maneuver to allow the
vehicle behind to get out
Thank You ver will clamp a lot with the
officers as well and you further
questions all right sir thank you cancel
ours alone and we'll move on to our next
speaker which is Victoria Paul thank you
for bearing with us again three minutes
I'm sure you're well aware that we'll
you'll require a warning after seconds
okay I think thank you
Jemma I speak in support of the
application live in response to the
parish councils good comments and behalf
of that client the merits of the
application had been fully addressed in
the offices report submitted to the
committee and we have submitted a
supplemental planning statement which I
think has been emailed to committee
members which has sought to address the
specific comments made by the parish
council firstly please assure the
committee there of our clients intent to
deliver quality housing for only for ill
minton so specifically smaller units
which are desperately needed in the area
secondly if granted the development will
be developed developed within this final
year using local contractor similar to
local developments has been carried out
in Arlington the present thirdly has a
charted Arabiya practice specializing
conservation and built environment are
we committed to design and deliver weld
considered developments specific
respectful of context and local
vernacular finally to address the
specific matters raised by the parish
council firstly a surge there's been no
objection from Senate rent
however we are happy to take a condition
to serve the properties with the
biodigester there's adequate space to to
achieve that and I think you thought
that's also noted within the offices
report secondly parking has been raised
earlier to this evening a 3-bedroom
property requires two parking spaces
we've shown two parking spaces
however the gardens are sufficiently
large and should three parking spaces
being required that's easily
accommodated also the private driveway
is wide enough and I think on a an
updated plan I think we've shown a
passing by in Magni could equally
provide visitor parking to conclude I
trust that the committee will see the
merits of the scheme and support the
officers recommendation
but this application also must make note
that it wasn't loaded the dippers
application site already has an extant
permission for a large 4 bedroom house
and so did you so it already has an
application approval for change thank
you I'm you mentioned the bio digester I
think you said pretty sure I'd know what
it is but I don't miss that how it works
would still not have to get rid of waste
a bio just a biodigester biologically
eats a sewage yeah and discharges fresh
water and it has to be located with a
specific distance away from the front
properties and in accordance with
building regulations and that the site
is adequate to to allow the siting the
biodigester biologically clears but
you'd still have the same quantity of
fluid going into the drainage is that
correct you might not know that you have
a drainage expert you may be if you're
not that's fine I'll ask but
biodigesters are not normally not a not
connected to the mains drainage it's a
solution for housings off main drainage
thank you Jeff
clearly it identifies in the report that
the Parish Council is not averse to
development and obviously that the site
already has an extent permission can you
just advise in view of that what sort of
tation you've undertaken with the Parish
Council and local villagers on this
particular proposal no specific
consultations have taken place with the
parish there'd be no local objections
neighbors or and no neighbors have
connected my client specifically wish to
provide smaller units than the bigger
units he's developed to two-bedroom
properties he actually wants to retain
them for rental actually more mundane
things and biases the questions of this
this parking provision bothers me a bit
it cropped up two or three times tonight
and what was happening earlier this
calendar year was that effectively
proposals for because there's shame
tends to say please hey can we get from
the question please
well I was gonna introduce the question
that's right but I think it's important
I should make the point that too is not
necessarily the right answer because we
had a major debate in L peg as rounding
things up now mace is clearly unhappy
about me extending the argument into
this line but but it effectively bring
some cases if we round up it will be a
requirement for three so the question is
can that extra space be accommodated I'm
happy to reiterate I believe that the
the scheme can accommodate additional
parking it was noted that only one
property has a parking access off the
public highway three properties has
parking of the private of the private
drive and the private Drive has ability
to provide visitor parking which I think
would be the key thing
to the other side of the driveway I
think there is a novice we submitted an
updated landscape plan in which had a
lay-by between the trees - to the left
those are widening of the roadway so
this plan is potentially not it's
potentially not the up-to-date plan yeah
so I think I think we did allow for
visitor parking there's a part we
thought that we ought to provide a
processing base on the along with the
trees all along the other side we're
talking about a normally pump it down to
the water table just as an observation
as well as a question I notice there's a
willow tree on the building again
observations no question on the opposite
side that they think have you made sure
that the buildings are foundations are
far enough away from that not to cause
any problems because willow trees are
renowned for undermining sir sight
investigations have been carried out on
the site because the previous
application sorry the previous
application which has approval the
Foundation's already in will have to dig
up the previous foundations which are on
the site of the house at the front those
foundations already in the house and
well thank you very much Matt Damon
we're going to point some clarification
there to the offices who need to know a
lot more about buyers
parking spaces private roads routes
willow trees at such as well feel free
to catch the richest question thank you
and so the obvious first question Elly
is do we have an updated layout plan
that shows any form of lay-by or is this
the only one we've got
not to my knowledge this appears it's
not my application but on the file I
need EMS this is the latest one which
was received on the 23rd of July okay
it concerns me that the agent has
suggested that there is an updated
version I don't know if you've got time
to check I would also like to understand
a little bit more about this biodigester
and how it works if you're able to
inform me in terms of the check that's
what we were carrying out a second ago
and we can confirm that the plan you see
in front of you is the most recent one
the council's got in these records sorry
and your question was about the bio
digester at the moment what the proposal
is in terms of officers recommendation
is to condition fowl sewage in the usual
way and we've done that on the basis
that 720 raised no objection at that
point the applicant could come in either
with what was been mentioned tonight or
connection to the fowl so uh and at that
point seven Trent would be consulted and
would if there was a problem raised
objection at that point if there was a
capacity issue has been alleged Rock can
I just ask a question about the elements
and in the response on page 16 page 62
number four it refers to policy hd5 of
the Ellington neighborhood development
plan saying a courtyard or ribbond
development would be
suitable so how much weight as that got
this stage that documents at a very
early stage in its progress it hasn't
got any weight at this stage it will
gather weight as it goes forward
cognizant of what it says their policy
hd5 members obviously would have to
consider what's in front of them
therefore they would have to look at
what's in front of them as I said and
decided that causes some form of harm
the fact that there's local community
develop the site in a certain way in a
document that doesn't have full weight
yet isn't a reason to object to that
layout in itself obviously if members
look at it and feel that there's some
other reason in terms of design or
street scene or whatever it may be then
that may constitute a reason to object
to you know because catch their brain is
not unable to attend just like to read
out a little statement from councillor
Bryan Terrell due to unforseen avoid the
unforeseen unavoidable family
circumstances I'm afraid that short
notice after you my apologies for
tonight's meeting what would request the
Chairman read out the following
submission in respect of this
application the Parish Council quite
correctly raised concerns about the
infrastructure in its ancient Cotswolds
village although they don't object in
print support development they still
raise major concerns although WCC
highways and 17 water raise their
concerns the Parish Council and local
residents have real concerns especially
with regard to surface water and sewage
we're more investigations are urgently
needed you have already heard from
Council Osborne so there's no need for
me to reiterate in respect of these
concerns a verne to say that is alleged
7/10 of not thumb works to increase
capacity as promised more properties
have been built since then there are
obviously capacity problems is raw
sewage has been forced out of manhole
covers are no reason
this will improve until sudden chant
increase capacity omni spices learn
permanent permission should be refused
until adequate infrastructure is
improved ice poly promised by seven
chant in 2011
seven seven years ago I asked you to
support the almonds and parish council
yours cancer brain any other points of
clarification seems like we've been
debating this one for ages in the con
round in circles who would like to start
on the debate catch the Barnes son
Calipari as I can see I appreciate the
sewage problem we've got a barn up the
road which has got this system twelve
palsy let's and the spreads are praying
nice both for people to come to this
face because that's the place where
they're really growing where the water
comes which is pumped out and under the
ground I think also one big house is pop
people used to build three or four
smaller ones is more appropriately to
believe so I appreciate that the concern
of the of the parish council in the
sewage but that as far as artists can
concerned has been addressed looks to me
as though there is a concern over
parking but I can't say that that can be
a planning reason particularly if the
the road is it looks to me looks to be
wide enough to say two cars anyway so
thank you canceled Brian for that
response that was something very
interesting your first part especially
catch the parade
I hope you're not mentioning sprites at
the moment Thank You chair Ellington is
is one of the most desirable villages
that we have
on the sort of edge of the Cotswolds I
would say and I just think it's rather
refreshing that the applicant has has mu
is moving against developing a huge
house which you will find a lot in terms
as you approach ill mminton and coming
through at Minton and I just think it's
very refreshing and pleasing to see some
smaller properties they won't be
affordable because it will maintain is a
very desirable village however I think
great attention has been paid to the
street scene it looks obviously that the
the stone will reflect the the yellow
iron stone that is a particular feature
of the village and providing there of
the the applicants agent has mentioned
the biodigester to hopefully address the
sewage problems providing we've got that
I can see no reason to object because I
think the the gardens are large enough
to provide additional parking area if if
the purposes of the property all those
who are living in the property feel that
they need more parking space so I can't
see I take on board the points that the
world member has made but I think the
applicants agent was evening is
demonstrating that they will investigate
and look at solutions and it's always
encouraging when agents look at
solutions to overcome objections so I
would be happy to second this proposal I
disagree with the way you say this is
laudable that the agent is agreed to
make some changes always open to changes
regarding the parking and disourage case
the fielding
eventually improved can how easy to turn
the biodegradable into the sewage system
I think we'll leave that to offices to
sort out and I think we've got a
reasonable condition in number fourteen
far than water surface change details to
be agreed and then a gray bar seven
churned who would then object if if it's
not appropriate so I think I think that
comes it you move on to looking for a
proposal I was so confused by the
sprouts I wasn't sure whether where
we've gone are you happy with the the
conditions that we proposed with it with
the clarity regarding parking spaces and
the the barges digester
the surface water journey yeah as you
said condition fourteen would cover the
drainage area so we've had a proposed in
the second all those in favor
thank you committee was almost a grant
application 1800 six seven six if you
are Nolan's cottage and we are no urgent
business so I want to bring that to the
meeting thank you